freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ich habe einen besonderen gast
heute den lieben maxi erinnert sich ich
habe kochen max ist sternekoch und heute
eine ganz besondere aufgabe die sich
hierauf bezieht was haben wir denn du
hast mich mal gefragt und nach dem motto
ein bisschen fast food in anders machen
und einen weiteren mann das gute stück
was es geworden ist es ist ein döner
oder mir drin ein höherer erzählt ein
titel gelesen aber ein ganz klassischer
löhne eine besonderheit bei der
bestellung die soße ist extra mir ist
das gute stück dabei geht es mir meine
aufgabe ist diesen bilder zu einem gummi
es wird schwer da kann dann du ich bin
gespannt was macht es gibt diese tech
talks das habe ich gesehen und
inspiriert mit boehner noch niemals
irgendjemand gemacht und seinem vorgehen
die kreativität an den tag legen darf
ist noch nicht sehr gespannt ich habe ja
ein bisschen gedanken gemacht wie wir
hier quasi dieses dieses gute stück ein
bisschen anders machen damit quasi jetzt
hier das gebackene brot natürlich sind
auch hübsch aus welcher mit den einmal
auf haben jetzt hier quasi dass das
fleisch meistens in der regel immer
hinten oder kalb die gurken salat
weißkraut g20 ein bisschen geizig mit
tomate anscheinend aber wird die idee
die quasi jetzt dahinter steckt werden
uns erst mal als baseline werden wir was
ganz klassisches machen nämlich im
konzern ab dass ein tomaten und salat du
willst ein bisschen penguins erweitern
kv oliven bisher und dieselöl aus dem
brot werden fotos gemacht damit haben
wir das schon mal weg aus der gurke und
dem eisbergsalat werden wir einen sud
machen ok gefüge auch ein bisschen hier
in feta käse verarbeiten soweit noch
alles ist es ja schon von
fünf euro für das männchen bei zehn euro
für 19 50 filmen und ich will hier noch
höher wir müssen noch über dann
natürlich das fleisch was willst du
jetzt damit machen und ich glaube da
hast du die goldene hingegen gebracht
lasst uns doch dieses einfach aufträgen
so schön und musik 220 jetzt jetzt kommt
entwickelt klassischer beim noch immer
so sind die wähler zeige ich auch
bearbeiten wollen so also manche sagen
sind es nur eine chance und wenn wir
einfach drüber stellt mit joghurt mit
schaf alles klar die werden wir nehmen
mit kräuterbutter verrühren über dieses
aufgedrehte fleisch von dir stellen in
dem backofen erwärmt und immer ein
bisschen parmesan thema italien so ein
bisschen gratiniert dass es so laufen
wird denn so ein hart wie ein turm nach
herborn ja super los geht's perfekt wie
fangen wir jetzt an dass sie
erst mal das ding auseinander bauen oder
wenn du willst kannst du dir das fleisch
raussuchen ja das schöne dass das so am
stück geschnitten wird das heißt man
kann es auch leicht aufdrehen das ist
wir würden und ich hoffe wir finden es
noch ein anderes stück
tomaten das was ihr schon mal beiseite
wenn du willst kannst du aus dem
fladenbrot gut ausschneiden gab die
haushalte getauscht so schön wie möglich
in der die hoch zur show also kleine
möglich
dafür werden aber erst mal was für ein
guter koch du eigentlich bist
bin ich jetzt eigentlich ein sternekoch
wenn ich jetzt bei dem mit koch
die drei jahre lang die nervige
hauskredite dann auf wanderjahre gehen
willst wenn du dann bereit fürs kreisen
dein leben unterzuordnen für alles
andere dann ist klappt dann erkennst du
glaubst so max würde ein abend bei euch
bestehen
ich glaube ich habe noch einen ganzen
tag für das ich eindeutig wünschen wo
ist die konsole wo es dann kann ich die
füße hochlegen aber einen tag auf jeden
fall deswegen machen wir doch einfach
mal so ich lade dich für einen tag hier
mit ein bei uns einen zacken zu kommen
also soll ich mit leuten heute noch die
antwort ist klar
dass angst wenn ich jetzt wirklich
arbeit gesund da einen tag machst du das
ein tag
so für das partielle eigentlich dieser
teppich bleiben die tomaten rot aber da
ist in der regel bei dem letzten für die
hochwertigsten sind danach viel
schrecken und wir haben nicht so viel
glück hatten dass allzu viel drin waren
und lassen wir einfach ein bisschen
immobilie dann geht gerne kruthoff
beigeben und nach der hälfte der zeit
wegen so langsam fast einig weiter
ansonsten einfach viel zu sehr lieben
vater gefangen werden automatisch
[Musik]
ausgeschnitten und wörter so mit meinem
brot gestellt wie man aber wirklich
schmeckt sind seien länger als zwei drei
minuten brauchen die auch nicht fangen
an zu arbeiten gerade wenn es mal soweit
bei italienischer hausmannskost
historisches politisches gericht leicht
angelehnt sein soll wird sie nicht so
genau nehmen der krieg nicht irgendwie
groß und klein schneiden klar wir
ergänzen ein paar produkte weil sonst
einfach kein rundes ding aber
kernbestandteile sind alle die diesen
bürger gibt also ich hätte jetzt auch
fünf kinder bestellen können nur die
tomaten aus dem bürger nehmen können
aber macht ja keinen sinn und dann
probieren wir diese tomaten waschen
nicht zu sein sondern rein über körper
das salz galt zu finden ok das heißt sie
müssen einmal kurz ein bisschen an hat
was sie diese mega sideboard von den
hier angetan denn jetzt machen wir den
happen aus ried durch direkt wunderbar
wenig verraten also in der ganzen kirche
durch die kräuter durch die oliven zu
machen jetzt können wir zwei punkte ist
etwas bisschen schwieriger aber noch
quasi hier so dass dem motto machen
außen sieht das sehr schön wieder hieß
es dass schönburg eisbergs seien einfach
nur zum frühen hast du nix ja du willst
den salat einfach mixen ja noch ein
salat mit sich und macht da draußen
sucht dann quasi wir sehen ja dass das
brot wird nachher sehr sehr krank
tomaten waschen das ein bisschen auch
weil ich weiß halt nicht wie sich das
fleisch nach er fällt kann sein dass das
jetzt nicht mehr ganz so saftig wird er
bis regeneriert singen möchte ich
einfach und nachher von der geschmack
textur einfach noch ein guthaben ist ein
bisschen frischer zu machen das hab ich
hab halt in diesem brotwürfel probieren
und das ist das kein thema bis jetzt
focaccia vordergrund er brauche jetzt
einfach noch was wollen wir wasser
zufügen was er hat geschmack
grundsätzlich 0 oder wir gehen
geschmacks seines wassers weise oder
gurke natürlich in jedem bürger
vertreten
und was wollen wir behalten in sutum den
songs geht ja jetzt gar nicht probieren
klar
dass mac auch richtig herzhaft irgendwie
feta käse hier ist jetzt ein bisschen
abgekühlt ersten mal ist etwas vor und
meistens esse ich habe einfach ein
bisschen kuscheln reinzukriegen mein
bauchgefühl sagt ich würde das jetzt
tapenade lernen wenn du probierst du
glaubst du dass er ist gerade jetzt wenn
wir das zusammen mit dem partner sagen
dem wir drauf geben hält es ja nachher
eigentlich in unserer in unserer
vorstellung wieder so ein bisschen
zusammen hier habe ich mal ausmacht und
wie immer auf die schamlosigkeit den
staffelsieg
ja ja
direkt am eingang wir haben die kräuter
einfach eine gekaufte geschmolzen und
haben die scharfe soße das ein bisschen
haut krümmel müssten unsere dönerfleisch
große zu geben und dann parmesan drüber
und dann er während des kurzen vergessen
wer jetzt eigentlich gleich wenn wir
jetzt hier quasi diese diese masse
draufgehen sorgt das automatisch auch
dafür das ist jetzt nicht ausdrucken
also wenn es einfach irgendwie sagen
geflügel von darüber gießen hast du
natürlich immer die gefahr wasser kann
verdampfen fest bleibt immer viel
mehr ist mehr würde ich sagen
jetzt haben wir alle bestandteile fertig
so durchsetzt die kräuterbutter du
riechst du bist hier ein bisschen
chillen wie parmesan
verhandelt mit uns mit unserer tomaten
mischung mit sieht man hier sehr schön
hoch flüssigkeit ist eingezogen wir hier
auf die tomate drauf drückt da ist noch
gut drin und jetzt sollte man eigentlich
nicht mehr zu lange wartet
einfach nur richtig
ist man so ein bisschen für auf eine
ebene zu bringen einzige zutat jeder
möglichen zugekommen ist sind die uli
genauso
wie schön das ausgiebige
die präzision und es hält was es
verspricht sie geht sogar noch auf hier
wie so eine blüte jetzt
[Musik]
wer sich noch irgendwo unsere
jungs richtig klassisch mal werden dann
anrichten
[Musik]
mit la für dich
das ist ein schöner leute das hier ist
mit boehner
die krank ist das jetzt sagen mal
ehrlich gerade älteste erwartet dass das
was dabei rauskommt ich meine wir uns
noch nicht gegessen aber
[Musik]
wunderschön ich bin gespannt ob es auch
so gut schmeckt wie es aussieht aber
optisch es erzählen kann man nichts
anderes sagen geh einfach mal hier so
mit ein bisschen von unserem gut daran
hier genau so ein schönes frische
traumschöne gabe
das ist so krass das ist möglich so
kraft also probieren das schmeckt
ultraleicht wirklich sehr sehr leicht
durch den sud ja auch wut heraus kann
also die gurke hat auch ordentlich
präsenz dieser textur unterschied so
dass knuspriges brot alles andere schön
weich eingekocht saftig ist krass ist
wirklich krass wo wir vielleicht einfach
mal so auf
jeden fall seine sachlichkeit behalten
nicht passt das gefühl diese
aromatisierung durch die butter hat sehr
gut funktioniert alles schmeckt noch mal
intensiver als bürger sowieso schon
schmecken weißt du einfach gesagt haben
wir machen diesen gurken peter liese cdu
zählt die junge presse der salat ist
sehr leicht aber dann beim fleisch sei
hier kommen sie ja nicht wie seine
helfer lohkirchen machen
die kräuterbutter also das ding ist was
ihr euch fragt schmeckt sagt öner
eigentlich nicht also es hat einen ganz
neuen geschmack ist ein ganz neues
eigenständiges gericht geworden war so
ein leckeres gericht maximus unbedingt
ausprobieren wenn es das so zu bestellen
gegen den rest wird es immer und immer
wieder stellen ist es so lecker wenn du
weißt was es war
wird zu sagen du kommst auf den
geschmack wenn ich dir die augen
verbindet dann wird schwierig ja also
voller erfolg vielen lieben dank dass du
das gemacht hat dass uns das gezeigt
hast hast du deine muskeln spielen
lassen das war ultra decker ich hoffe es
war genauso viel spaß beim anschauen
dabei zu sein einfach sagen bis zum
nächsten video client bin ich beim
attraktiv und wenn ihr ein anderes
gericht gefilmt zu haben holt schreibe
es in die kommentare
geile alltag wirklich voller erfolg
heftig also geil